[Musique]
voilà ça y est j'ai pu réserver mon
prochain week end à la mer avec mon
épouse
ce sera bien on va y aller en train bail
avec tout ce qu'on entend sur la planète
aujourd'hui le développement durable et
société en transition puis ça va nous
donner plutôt bonne conscience avec
notre chaudière au mazout
nos deux bagnoles nos trois enfants
alors sur les trous les 100 kilomètres
qu'on va faire pour aller jusqu'à la mer
vingt- à peu près 30 peut-être seront
associés à des combustibles fossiles
parce que l'électricité qui va faire
fonctionner le train est belle est
produite aujourd'hui en belgique par des
centrales thermiques qui fonctionnent au
gaz au pétrole et au charbon et 50
autres kilomètres vont être
indirectement associé à d'uranium
une autre matières extraites du sous-sol
parce que ce sont les centrales
nucléaires qui font fonctionner à peu
près 50% de l'électricité aujourd'hui en
belgique
c'est du propre tout ça heureusement on
sera nombreux d'entre eux on va pouvoir
partager les déchets radioactifs on va
pouvoir partager les émissions de co2
mais ouf
les 20 derniers kilomètres entre bruges
et au stand
ça sera associé à des énergies
renouvelables francky mais là aussi il
va falloir pas mal d'énergie du sous sol
est pas mal de ressources du sous sol
parce que pour fabriquer un aimant d'une
éolienne il va me falloir du néodyme et
plein d'autres éléments terres rares
mais les éléments que mène de l'est
familles en balade en tableau mais ne
lève il allait avoir plein d'ennuis avec
ce machin
il les a mis en bas du néodyme et
d'autres pour des panneaux
photovoltaïques qui va me falloir de
l'indium du gallium du cuivre de
l'argent est bien plein d'autres
éléments aussi du silicium notamment
mais heureusement j'ai pu réserver en
connectant tranquille alors ça c'est un
véritable consommateur de ressources du
sous sol du lithium pour sa batterie de
l'indium pour son écran plein du cuivre
de l'argent du tantale pour son
électronique est encore plein de terres
rares pour le faire fonctionner s'il
venait l'idée de téléphoner d'entre eux
je serai un vrais pilleurs de ressources
du sous sol aux indiens mais qu'est ce
qu'il a ce type il parle que de terre de
terres rares de sous sol bah oui je suis
géologue
mon métier c'est de suivre les filons
pour faire carrière mais j'ai plutôt
bonne mine sur la photo que vous voyez
je vais pas me plaindre parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de cailloux sympathique qui
viennent des entrailles de la terre des
saphirs des émeraudes parfait des pubs
et des diamants est salée diamant sas et
durable ces éternels mais si on prend
justement une fune image de ce que l'on
pourrait imaginer la cité de demain
qu'est ce qu'on voit ben on voit le le
vol majestueux des oiseaux le gaillard
qui promène son chien il ya le train de
tout à l'heure on voit un vélo tout s
est revenue tout et verdâtres mais si je
mets mes lunettes de géologues
qu'est ce que je vois vous voyez venir
évidemment du néodyme pour les aimants
des éoliennes tous les métaux qui vont
être nécessaires pour les panneaux
photovoltaïques le fer le manganèse pour
les silos vous raconte pas pour faire
fonctionner le train le calcaire
l'argile le sable pour le ciment et même
les charges métallique qu'on va observer
pour donner la couleur rouge du graffiti
à droite il faut des charges métalliques
mais c'est pas qu'une préoccupation des
géologues actuel ça c'est une vieille
histoire
les ressources du sous-sol votre prof
d'histoire vous l'a dit toutes les
sociétés se base sur les minerais les
techniques et les produits l'âge de la
pierre on exploiter des pierres et puis
on est passé à l'âge du cuivre est bien
guéri nana qui s'est dit mais si je mets
un autre métal dans le cuit je vais
passer à l'âge du bronze ça sera mieux
pour moi et puis on est passé à l'âge du
feu
r nous quittons actuellement l'air des
combustibles fossiles trop lentement et
on entre dans l'âge de l'électro on
exploite tous les éléments du tableau de
mendeleïev au dessus ou en dessous quel
qu'il soit les romains déjà connaissait
sept métaux qu'ils associaient au cet
astre facilement visible à l'époque
chaque astri chaque métal associé à un
jour de la semaine et évidemment à un
dieu vous allez voir c'est assez marrant
on va faire le petit jeu lundi manne
d'argent néerlandais c'est le jour de la
lune et la lune c'est un grand disque
d'argent dans le ciel mardi mars le dieu
la planète
c'est le jour du fer mercredi
aujourd'hui mercure la planète
le métal ça m'échappe d'un messager des
dieux jeudi jupiter celle éteint
vendredi
vénus la déesse de l'amour est le
symbole de la féminité c'est le symbole
du cuivre samedi saturday en anglais
saturne mais la maladie du plomb c'est
le saturnisme
samedi c'est jour du plomb dimanche
sunday le jour du soleil et le sol est
un grand disque d'or dans le système
alors depuis les romains on a plutôt de
la vanne on a largement intensifié nos
extraction on extrait autant depuis
trente ans que depuis toute l'histoire
de l'humanité on extrait chaque année
2,2 milliards de minerai de fer sur
terre bien plus qu'il ya dix ans
qui parle encore de rationalité là
dessus mais bon on a besoin de
ressources du sous sol mais soyons
pragmatiques
cette saison soyons pragmatiques et
comment fait on creuse alors vous
connaissez sûrement les grands trous les
grandes carrières alimenté par des
camions qui appartiennent à des grandes
multinationales aux capitaux gigantesque
et qui quotidiennement améliorent leurs
process et en tant que faire se peut de
diminuer leur impact environnemental en
mai si je mène un peul enquête et si je
prends mon déguisement de géo lors d'un
peu baroudeur
que vous dire qu'il ya une autre manière
d'extraire on appelle ça les creuseurs
artisanaux assez pudiquement alors
relégable creuse à l'appel et ils vont
remplir des sacs et vous allez voir que
les sacs c'est véritablement le fil
conducteur de tout chemin
les sacs parfois sont remplies par les
enfants est ce qu'il ya dans les sacs et
parfois lavé par les dames qui sont
totalement la botte il n'a qu'une du
contremaître locale
les gamins transportent les minerais
dans les sacs et il transporte tout ça
dans les coffres des voitures
et oui les sacs et les voitures
transportent les sacs dans des sur des
camions et nous on reste dans notre
voiture parce que on commence à sentir
que va être chouette histoire alors les
camions embarque les sacs devant ces
grandes balustrade voiliers vieux zinc
vieux bron ce vieil aluminium et on se
demandait c'est quoi les deux tuyaux qui
sont juste au dessus alors quand la
balustrade souvenez vous voyez que c'est
des hauts fourneaux en réalité et vous
connaissez les sacs et on va ressortir
les minerais des sacs pour couler des
lingots artisanaux bien moins beau que
les lingots légaux ça représente d'après
la banque mondiale pour certains
minerais dont certains produits de 60 à
90% l'extraction aujourd'hui pour les
ong c'est de l'esclavagé moderne
évidemment mais toujours d'après la
banque mondiale rien qu'en république
démocratique du congo
cinq cent mille à 2 millions creuseurs
qui font vivre jusqu'à 10 millions de
personnes aujourd'hui
alors si on va un peu plus au nord en
afrique un trou à nouveau alors là les
géologues
ils affluent évidemment on va avec la
route et qu'est ce qu'on voit à côté de
la route mais des gars qui creuse avec
les moyens du bord et creuse ce type de
choses et ils vont mettre les minerais
dans les sacs toujours les mêmes sacs en
toile de jute partout où vous allez et
c'est ça que vous voulez sur le dos d
âne et les ânes vont apporter les sacs
dans le coffre des voitures et le coffre
des voitures vont apporter les sacs sur
des camions mais tout bien pesé
s'il faut creuser préfères-tu qu'on
creuse à la pelle ou à la pelleteuse
alors on pourrait se dire ben essayons
d'extraire tout près de chez nous plutôt
d'aller si loin
bonne idée faire un petit circuit court
comme ça pour les ressources du sous sol
dans mon jardin
mais parce que quand je fais des travaux
chez moi j'analyse le sous-sol de mon
jardin
alors qu'est ce qu'il ya dans mon jardin
des éléments majeurs plus de 9,6 pour
cent silicium aluminium fer etc
mais en fait dans mon jardin j'ai tous
les éléments du tableau de mendeleïev
tous mais sont en élément mineur prépa
le jeu de mots en éléments mineurs ont
les 200 ppm parties par million
un élément d'un atome pour un million
d'autres atomes et dans mon jardin g27
ppm de néodyme super 000 27% de néodyme
donc pour transformer ça en aimant d'une
éolienne ça va me demander une telle
énergie que non vraiment cette idée de
faire un gisement néodyme dans mon
jardin cette idée un peu du plomb dans l
aile mais heureusement nous avons
d'autres ressources du sous sol en
wallonie on a été premier producteur de
plomb de zinc au 19e siècle mais encore
de la ressource notamment dans la région
de namur et dans l'est de la belgique
dans un village qu'on appelle plombières
de ressources du plomb et de la bière eh
bien vous imaginez une grande mine de
plomb aux alentours de namur serait
nickel st mais mine de rien cette idée
aussi prometteuse soit elle pour un
circuit court et bien serait rapidement
miné par les réactions caustique des
riverains l'effet nimby not in my
backyard je suis tout à fait d'accord
d'utiliser l'ensemble des métaux qui
sont dans cet appareil mais pas dans le
yard c'est une expression anglophone
pendant le yart qui est juste derrière
chez moi
et puis les
ces extractions elles ont laissé des
souvenirs un peu bizarre en wallonie
avec des noms comme germinal silicose
coup de grisou non cette histoire
d'extraction one chez moi en favorisant
bien sûr une approche strictement local
et en négligeant la proche globale du
développement durable alors si à part
moyen d'extraire avec des extractions
comment on peut faire on recycle en
effet on peut tenter de recycler à lorp
le recyclage pour certains ben c'est une
vraie mine d'or évidemment et plus de
recyclage
c'est sympa ça paye pas de mine mais si
je met à nouveau mes petites lunettes de
géologues qu'est ce que je peux vous
dire ben recycler les plusieurs dizaines
de métaux qui est là dedans mais chaque
métal en très petites quantités mais
c'est pas simple et même si on arrivait
à recycler à plus de 90% au premier
recyclage de 9% au 2ème recyclage 90% de
90% 81 % puis 73% 66% 59% 53% et dès le
7e recyclage je n'ai plus la moitié de
ce que j'avais au début je plombe un peu
l'ambiance là je vois bien dans
l'horreur on pourrait imaginer tous on
en sort maintenant parce qu'on est mené
depuis géologue
on pourrait imaginer que le concept de
développement durable qui se base sur
trois piliers social économique
environnemental et bien vu ce concept
avec une soutenabilité forte que j'aime
bien parce que vous avez la nature qui
englobe et sociale qui englobe
l'économique donc pas d'économie sans
sociale et pas d'économie et sociale
sans nature et bien que ce concept
exclut les ressources non renouvelables
du sous sol
mais en réalité homo sapiens n'a jamais
épuisé les ressources de son sous sol
quand on a quitté l'âge de la pierre il
y avait encore des pierres quand on a
quitté l'âge du cuivre il y avait encore
du cuir et on s'est dit ce serait quand
même mieux si se passe à l'âge du fer
mon bien-être en sera améliorée bien
quand on quitte l'âge du fer il a encore
dû faire nous quitterons l'âge des
combustibles fossiles
il y aura encore des combustibles
fossiles pétrole gaz charbon mais nous
aurons décidé nous citoyens que ce sera
quand même
mieux de passer dans l'âge l'électro
même s'il ya plein de soucis faudra pas
attendre l'épuisement
au propre comme au figuré on pourra y
aller parce que le quatrième pilier du
développement durable c'est la
participation citoyenne à partir de
maintenant je vous invite à ne plus
rester de marbre à aller au charbon à
regarder le monde qui nous entoure avec
des yeux de géologues en scrutant un peu
en creusant tous les métaux qui sont
présents dans tous les produits pas mal
c'est un dieu pour tout nouvel écran je
te demanderais bien petit peu diatomées
pour filtrer ma bière
tu n'aurais pas du calcaire pour
fabriquer mon sucre 1 je t'échange
revient un peu de rhodium compte du fer
et du manganèse pour fabriquer mon acier
alors conscient de l'omniprésence des
ressources du sous sol dans notre
environnement quotidien
il nous sera plus facile d'adopter un
comportement adéquat de citoyens en
rejetant certains produits et devant ma
fille mon fils là qu'il avait terrorisé
ou en réduisant certains produits
réduisant au en réparant lfr faune
aujourd'hui ont la particularité de
pouvoir se réparer beaucoup plus
facilement en réutilisant vous allez
chez vous en rentrant et vous ouvrir le
tiroir
on ne sait jamais vous allez voir tous
les trésors qu'il ya dedans ou en
recyclant et puis les faits nimby not in
my backyard c'est moi qui décide de la
sphère locale régionale environnementale
mais bon je tourne la pierre à personne
revenons aux romains il avait déjà une
approche transversale il mélanger les
disciplines transdisciplinaire
systémique dont on y revient à 7
rapprochement vers salle en effet la
lande fin de l'ère des combustibles
fossiles qui sont à la base de
l'émission de 40 gigatonnes de co2 dans
l'atmosphère lors une tonne de gaza peu
près une montgolfière dont 40 gigatonnes
c'est qu'on est aimé par an 40 milliards
de montgolfières de co2 et bien la lande
fin de l'ère des combustibles fossiles
va nous éviter bien des soucis et va en
créer d'autres tout aussi diversifié en
termes d'implication environnementales
sociétales sociales économiques
géopolitiques technologique
théologique philosophique juilla
géologiques comme en réalité nous avons
je mens besoin d'une approche
transversale vers laquelle doivent aller
les universités au modifiant quelque peu
leur cursus de bacheliers de master un
peu plus trop disciplinaire une approche
transversale vers laquelle doit
installer les administrations et les
politiques restructurant la fiscalité
une approche transversale vers laquelle
doivent aller également les compagnies
privées
en modifiant la sphère sociale de
travail de leurs employés et une
approche transversale vers laquelle
doivent-elles les citoyens munis de
plusieurs paires de lunettes facilement
ajustable et interchangeables en réalité
l'avenir est entre nos mains nous
citoyens pour une gestion durable des
ressources non renouvelables sous sol
selon une approche résolument
transdisciplinaire à plusieurs gsm
échelle locale nimby régionale globale
pour que nos enfants puissent eux aussi
jouir de noces d'argent de platine d'or
de diamants parce que le mariage c'est
aussi une affaire de géologues
je vous souhaite un moral d'acier une
santé de fer pas trop de pieds de plomb
merci ciao
[Musique]